Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetle popcorn
Tim Burton had a great time in The Adams
Family world and you probably missed
this sneaky Beetlejuice Easter egg
Netflix's runaway success Wednesday has
a lot of Secrets based on The Addams
Family daughter of the same name played
by Jenna Ortega Wednesday places the
iconic character into Nevermore Academy
a school that holds a special place in
the history of the spooky family on
account of Gomez and Morticia having met
there of course one of the best people
to bring this new Wednesday show to the
small Silver Screen is the legendary Tim
Burton made famous for his Endeavors
like Edward Scissorhands Batman and
Beetlejuice Burton has a rather distinct
style that is almost immediately
apparent to anybody who has had any
previous experience with the director
lately get a load of me speaking with
Empire Tim Burton spoke about what
inspired him to take on Wednesday and
explained when I read the script it just
spoke to me about how I felt in school
and how you feel about your parents how
you feel as a person it gave The Adams
Family a different kind of reality it
was an interesting combination Tim
Burton and The Adams Family is
definitely an interesting company nation
and considering the status of Burton's
Works in pop culture it's no surprise
that Wednesday is filled to the brim
with clever callbacks and nods to his
other movies throughout Wednesday there
are tons of Easter eggs inspired by Tim
Burton's other famous works which was
very intentional production designer
Mark skrun delighted in filling scenes
with homages to Burton's body of work
one particular location and Wednesday
that's absolutely adorned with burden
references is the weathervane's coffee
shop that many Nevermore Academy
students frequent if you pay close
attention you can see that the
weathervane's channel is the essence of
two Burton movies one is inspired by The
Headless Horseman from Sleepy Hollow and
one emulates the hat from Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory however these two
examples were far from the only Easter
eggs and there were several that were
explicitly designed to reference
previous Adams Family shows and movies
like Pilgrim world and the archery scene
which are nods to Camp Chippewa and
Adam's family values and Wednesday's
well-known affinity for archery it's an
American Pie bald eagle
but aren't they extinct they are now and
the secret way into Nevermore Academy
secret society consists of the two
finger snaps made Popular by The Adams
Family theme song of course one cannot
put burton-based Easter eggs in
Wednesday without involving the Ghost
with the most released in 1988
Beetlejuice tells the story of a
recently deceased couple played by Alec
Baldwin and Gina Davis who has to come
to terms with their status as ghosts and
the family that moves into their house
seeking to restore their former peace
and donorship of the home the previously
mentioned couple conjures up a bio
Exorcist known as Beetlejuice
considering the lasting popularity of
Beetlejuice among Tim Burns fans it
makes perfect sense as to why there are
multiple Beetlejuice references in
Wednesday yep bunch of losers
you're working with a professional here
probably the easiest of these references
is the shrunken head that resembles the
big game hunter in the afterlife waiting
room from Beetlejuice upon the desk of
principal Weems however there is a more
subtle reference in Wednesday that
emulates the famous white and black
striped suit made Popular by Beetlejuice
in episode 7 titled if you don't woe Me
By Now Wednesday and Tyler watch these
supposed horror movie Legally Blonde
while eating popcorn at crackstone's
Crypt however eagle-eyed viewers or
those with their brightness settings
turned up may notice that the popcorn
bag has the same color scheme and look
as beetlejuice's typical suit which was
definitely intentional luckily for
Wednesday and Tyler they weren't
immediately compelled to sing day though
this is a great Easter egg for longtime
fans of Burton
[Music]